Is the internet
working for you?
Mmm, let me see.
No.
Give me my phone, I'll call.
Uh, maybe it's better
if I call.
No, I know what you're thinking,
but I'm not gonna freak out.
I'm in like
a really good place.
You sure?
Oh my God, it's a phone call,
like, relax.
♪
You got this, girl.
(line tone ringing)
(woman)
Please listen carefully
as our menu has changed.
For English,
please press one.
English.
Are you currently
a Time Warner Cable customer?
Yes.
Do you want help
with your account?
Yes.
Did you say you want
to add a land line?
Representative.
All of our representatives
are busy.
Please hold for the next
available representative.
(Muzak playing)
Thank you for calling
Time Warner Cable.
This is Janardhan, may I have
your account number, please?
Okay, it's 1-6-1-9--
Please hold while I look up
the first half
of your account number.
Oh, yeah, that doesn't
make any sense.
Please don't leave me-- Hello?
(Muzak playing)
Aah, you're fine.
Come on, God.
(dial tone)
Hello, Janardhan, Janardhan!
No, (bleep) no (bleep) ass
(bleep) my whole (bleep).
Janardhan!
F... (bleep)!
(wind howling)
English.
Representative.
Person! Human person!
(whimpering)
Thank you for calling
Time Warner cable.
This is Janardhan,
may I help--
1-6-1-9-6-3-4.
I need your account number,
please.
Janardhan, just be real
right now, man.
Be real!
Ma'am, let me transfer you
to our transfer department.
Please hold for...
No-no-no-no-no!
No-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no!
No, Janardhan!
Janardhan!
(bleeps).
I mean, I was gonna go back
to school but like, for what?
Like, for what?
We're all going to
the same place, anyway.
We have our relationships.
Like that's all we have
in this world.
That's who we are.
(beeping)
(Janardhan)
We'll need the serial number
of the first modem
you ever owned.
(bleep) you, Janardhan!
(bleep) you.
And what was the nickname
your mother gave you
when you were seven?
I know you're probably
like a really good guy.
It's not your fault,
you're probably like--
You have interests
and you probably have like
a family or like a cat
or something, but like--
(bleep) you.
(sobbing)
Like, why are you doing this
to us, Janardhan?
(crying)
♪
♪ But I'm in so deep ♪
♪ You know I'm such
a fool for you ♪
♪ You got me wrapped around
your finger ah ha ha ♪
♪ Do you have
to let it linger? ♪
♪ Do you have to,
do you have to ♪
♪ Do you have
to let it linger? ♪
♪ Oh I thought
the world of you ♪
♪ I thought nothing
could go wrong ♪
♪ But I was wrong ♪
♪ I was wrong if you ♪
♪ If you could get by ♪
♪ Trying not to lie ♪
I love you, Janardhan.
I love you too, Mrs. Scuva.
(whispers)
Do it.
♪ And I wouldn't
feel so used ♪
(gunshot)
(beeping)
Oh, the router just needed
to be restarted.